أرى اللون كشكل من أشكال التواصل
أشعر أنه يروي القصة عندما أنظر
إلى الألوان كما في لوحة أعتقد
تلقائيًا أنه يمكنني وضع ذلك في المقدمة ،
اسمي دانيال مون وأنا مصفف شعر
بدأت في الدخول فيه لأول مرة
شعر عندما كنت في الحلاق الأسود في سلاح مشاة البحرية
لنفسي ولأصدقائي الآخرين ،
لقد مُنحت إذنًا بالخروج من
سلاح مشاة البحرية للذهاب إلى كونها
مقيدة للغاية في الجيش أعتقد
أن الخروج منها لم يكن هناك
قيود مفروضة علي لذلك
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالإنشاء ، أقسم نوعًا ما
بأنني لم أقيد نفسي أبدًا من
القيام بشيء مثل ما أردت القيام به
، وبطريقة ما توصلت إلى هذه الطريقة السحرية
لتلوين الشعر ، لذا فإن تلوين الشعر يدويًا
ينظر إلى الرأس على أنه
لوحة قماشية سواء  إنه شعر قصير أو شعر طويل
أن أكون قادرًا على الرسم عليه فقط كما
لو كان منحوتة
أجد الإلهام في كل مكان أنظر فيه إلى
عالم الفن الذي أنظر فيه إلى عالم المجلات
الذي أبحث فيه في الكتب التي
لا يفكر فيها الناس في البحث متى
أنا أختار الألوان والتصميمات التي
أتخيلها مثل لوحة الشطرنج هذا
اللون الأرجواني هنا هذا الخيط هنا ، هل يمكنني توصيل هذا اللون بهذا اللون الذي
أنظر إليه من كل زاوية أعلى
وأسفل يسارًا ويمينًا ثم ألعب
بهذه الأنواع المختلفة من الأشكال
لا أفكر في أن أكون مختلفًا عن
مصففي الشعر الآخرين
الذين أنشأتهم عملاً مختلفًا بالنسبة
لي ، فهو يختلف عن آخر قطعة لي ،
أعتقد أن الناس يصبغون شعرهم للحصول على المتعة
لخلق شخصية ممتعة.
بعض
التعاون الرائع مع مادونا كاتي
بيري ، نيكول ريتشي وزوي كرافيتز ،
العمل الذي أقوم بإنشائه مؤقت وهذا
هو رومانسي لأنه يتلاشى
الشعر يكبر ، يمكنني قضاء 3 ساعات و 6
ساعات على قطعة ثم بعد ذلك يمكن أن
تخرج من الباب وبعد ذلك  لم أره أبدًا
مرة أخرى
وأحب أنه شكل فني
يتلاشى ، وأحب الاستمرار في
ابتكار شيء ما
لم أره من قبل
[موسيقى]